first big broad question for you because
there's so many exciting elements of
this production going into filming which
part of it were you most excited to
tackle but then also what is something
that wound up being more creatively
fulfilling than you ever could have
imagined wow so I think going into it um
the most exciting thing was just the
canvas space it's like I've never had
the opportunity to make something I mean
we shot for a hundred and something days
you know my first movie I shot in 19
days I think my second movie I got it up
to 24. so like this was you know playing
on a canvas that was so much bigger uh
and just as a director there was very
little that I wanted to do that they
said no to or say oh we don't have the
money or the time for that you know it
was sort of like they really encouraged
me to uh to think big and to actually so
that was really cool and the thing that
I knew would be great but you just never
know before you start casting is the
experience answer the actors
um and obviously it's a Disney movie
it's a big Studio Movie I knew I'd be
working with movie stars and what you
know and everyone in this film is a big
movie star but they're also really
wonderful actors and performers uh and I
learned how to direct you know doing
theater uh and so I I have a real love
for actors and I I it's not just about
looking cute it's like let's really find
a character here let's find a way to
tell this story even better than the
most obvious thing to think of and
everybody uh across the board was so
passionate about that process and it was
truly truly bonding fun familial
experience working with these folks
doesn't surprise me to hear that I'll go
to Casting next um can you tell me about
your process when working with Carmen
Cuba who's like one of the best in the
business and also because I have a
feeling she was heavily involved in
finding Chase who is also absolutely
phenomenal in this film well that's the
thing about Carmen is that she she
thinks about casting in the way that I
do it it sort of is like you absolutely
want to find the perfect person for the
role but you also want a surprise you
want somebody who you didn't think you
wouldn't think of like who would think
of Owen Wilson as a priest you know what
I'm saying like who would think of uh
and of course Chase Dillon the first
person she said the first person just
out the gate and and of course I'm like
you know I just seen him in uh in Barry
Jenkins uh show uh I was about to call
it emancipation but uh uh uh the
Underground Railroad excuse me and I
thought he was so brilliant in that and
he is truly a remarkable young man but
the thing about Carmen is that she knows
how to use a cast to tell multiple
stories not just the story that's on the
page but other kinds of cultural stories
putting people in places you don't
expect to necessarily see them and and
put it you know there's so many cameos
in this movie too and one of the things
that we had a lot of fun doing on my
last film bad hair is making a meal a
lot of these little small moments and
parts and so there were so many
opportunities to do this in this film
and I think she just knocked it out of
the park all right I'll bring up uh one
of your I mean this isn't a cameo this
is a significant role in the film I want
to talk about Jerry Leto and working
with him because there's a quote that I
I caught in the production notes here so
he's giving a voice performance but you
said he put so much work into the
character and so much thought into every
choice that he makes so can you give me
an example of a choice he made in his
voice performance that someone might say
like that's trivial that's a little
thing but it wound up being really
impactful on shape in that character
well first of all when we first started
talking about the character I mean we
had a real In-Depth series of
conversations about where this guy is
from what he is think you know because
he is just a he's he starts off as a
visual sight gag on this ride that
doesn't even have a name eventually the
you know fans are calling him hatbox
ghosts and now he's Canon and now he's
so like you have some things to go off
of but not really a lot else you know uh
and and down to uh not just the accent
but the way in which he sort of Savers
certain kinds of words he really you
know we we came up with a character that
really does delight in putting people
down and being as Petty as possible and
doing so you know in the most elaborate
uh fashion and so uh we had a lot of fun
we uh you know we we played with the
dialogue that we had but but Jared also
we just played they were just like long
stretches of Jared just talking you know
as we're trying to figure out like well
how does he laugh and like how does he
like what does he make fun of about
people and and you know what are his
favorite syllables we spent a lot of
time in the Weeds on that and I I think
it really shows I mean you would never
know it was Jared Leto unless someone
told you that's how complete a character
it is uh and yet it's really thoughtful
and delightful I thought it was really
fun now because I'm curious what is his
favorite syllable oh God lots of s's
lots of s's and guttural slaps
lots of those
I love that all right I have uh two
personal questions inspired by this
movie first I just absolutely love the
idea of ghost winks and I'm a big
believer that they do actually happen so
have you experienced one and if so what
happened I've experienced a lot of ghost
Wings in my life I mean I was raised um
I was raised Catholic and my family is
from Louisiana so it's a very specific
flavor of Creole black Catholic culture
and growing up that way ghosts were just
a matter of fact you know what I'm
saying like there was nothing spooky or
it was you expected that to happen and
uh I I gotta say the one that I think
about often is um a close friend of mine
in high school his name is Beyonce I
named a character after him in my TV
show dear white people so I've told this
story before but
um he passed at a really young age and a
voice message that he had left me maybe
two years prior uh and that I had heard
at the time and deleted it to me it was
just very innocuous it it popped up on
my phone the day he passed uh out of
nowhere and listening to this message in
that context it was a goodbye message it
was he thanked me for our friendship and
he recounted on you know some of the
good things that we were going you know
that we've done together and and he kind
of put a blessing on my life and my
future endeavors and again when he sent
that message to me two years before I
was like oh that's sweet but it coming
back on my phone after I absolutely
deleted it the day I found out he passed
certainly felt like a ghost wink and I
remember I was like in the target of
like a Ross or I I was in the parking
lot of a Target under Ross and I just I
just wept because I felt him I felt his
presence with me what a beautiful
example mine's a red bird in my backyard
I'm convinced it's my grandfather yeah
absolutely just shows up exactly when I
need him yep yeah I could talk to you
all day about your movie I'm not allowed
to I have to leave I don't say
congratulations thank you so much I
appreciate it such a good time